So today, we've been talking about learning by correcting mistakes.
We started off by revisiting explanation based learning and
incremental concept learning, in those lessons we were dealing with a small
number of examples coming in one by one. We dealt with the same thing here, but
here we had the additional feedback about whether or not our initial conclusion
was right or wrong. We then talk about isolating mistakes. This was similar to
our problem diagnosis. Given a mistake how do we narrow down our reasoning to
find where that mistake occurred. Then we talked about explain the mistake.
This is key both to building human like agents and to enabling the agent to
correct its mistake. Only by explaining the mistake can the agent correct it
efficiently. And after those phases correction becomes a much more
straightforward task. Next time we'll talk about meta-reasoning in more detail.
For example here we've discussed mistakes in knowledge but what about mistakes
in reasoning? What about mistakes in architecture? What about gaps instead of
mistakes where we don't know something instead of knowing something incorrectly?
We'll talk about all that next time.